we're going to move on now to something
really amazing in the State of Florida
you are watching on your screen now if
we can pull it up NASA's biggest and
most powerful rocket ever lighting up
Florida Sky early this morning as it
blasted off toward the moon all part of
the agency's Artemis project which aims
to Have astronauts walking on the lunar
service once again within the next five
years but there have been setbacks along
the way it's not easy going to the Moon
Mark Strassman has the story now from
Kennedy Space Center
liftoff of Artemis one as a human-made
spectacle this Artemis one launch was
tough to beat NASA's most powerful
rocket ever pushing through Florida's
night sky and Earth's heavy atmosphere
with 8.8 million pounds of thrusts today
we got to witness the world's most
powerful rocket take the Earth by its
edges and shake the wicked out of it and
it was quite a sight on Monday morning
next week Orion will fly within 60 miles
of the lunar surface then push 40 000
miles beyond the moon for space High
drama its Glimpse back on Earth after
orbiting the moon Orion will re-enter
Earth's atmosphere for the mission's top
priority testing the capsule's heat
shield against temperatures of 5 000
degrees about half as hot as the surface
of the Sun from Houston Rick lebrode
will lead the team in Mission Control a
successful Mission could lead to a new
era of moonwalking it NASA is hoping for
a crude lunar Landing later this decade
fair to say A lot's on the line here oh
yeah that's very fair to say I mean yeah
we got to have a successful flight
otherwise you're not putting astronauts
on the next next mission
and what Elantra was early this morning
in an instant The Flash from the
controlled explosion under the rocket
turned night into day and then there was
the rumble of nearly 9 million pounds of
thrust and the sonic wave that washed
over all of us standing on this roof and
made the roof shutter you can expect to
see some remarkable images in the days
they had this spacecraft has 13 cameras
on board images you'll see all the way
to December 11th the schedule splashed
down off the coast of San Diego
back to you guys that's cool mark thank
you very much I love it